hey everyone welcome back to the
waterload podcast thanks again for
tuning in to another episode and if this
is your first time well then welcome to
the podcast hopefully you enjoy it
because there is plenty of lads who have
been on already which you can scroll
back and listen to but this episode is
brought to you by pomery's coffee the
best coffee bean in the business who are
now giving water lead listeners a
special 20 off discount for all your
coffee and tea needs just enter the code
lad 03 that's capital lad 03 at the
checkout to claim your discount or you
can head over to wadella.com and all
information is there and as always if
you enjoy this episode please give it a
share it's very much appreciated and i
have an absolute lad for you here so
let's get to it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh what a lad well today i have an
absolute treat for you with one of the
biggest lads from the south he was a
southland stag legend and he's played
over a hundred games for the highlanders
which included scoring one of the most
debated tries of all time he's also
played for the new zealand maldives and
of course he's reached the ultimate goal
of becoming an all black more recently
he spent some time in japan with the
black rams and now he's over in france
dominating for bats
and if you talk to any of the highlander
lads they will tell you that he is the
ultimate lad it is the great elliot
dixon welcome mate what an intro what an
intro mate making shivers give me
shivers the ray warren podcast
exactly
right how are you though i i hear you've
been battling covert the last week how
was that yeah i got covered again i got
it first in japan um about a year ago
then
got the double vax thought i'd be sweet
got covered again and then i've been in
bed for five days my wife has been
looking after the three kids and
but dropping off at school picking them
up and and looking after me upstairs so
um yeah horrible but
glad to get out of isolation get the
negative test and um back into training
and all that sort of jasper was it the
same strand was it were they both
covered or omnichrome i couldn't tell
you i don't know what um leather and the
greek alphabet we're up to at the moment
but uh it was one of them
it wasn't as bad as the japanese one to
be fair it's just because i think i had
it without the vaccination
um and yeah i was i was down for about
nine ten days with with that one um
but i think it was omnicron because it
wasn't as bad and it was over pretty
quickly
you must have sloppy hygiene to be
catching so much cover do you
yeah i'm blaming it on the kids blaming
the kids going to school and bringing
that covert that's not me
it's not me i promise the promise is not
me wait it must have been tough for your
wife though to be fair um looking after
the three kids and yourself
yeah well looking after four kids um
yeah she's um she's been a trooper um
especially coming over here different
language
moving 30 hours at least away and then
we've covered
and
all the border controls and miq just
only recently
announcement today
that there might be a better bit of
light at the end of the tunnel but um
yeah it's been it's been tough on on
everyone but um especially
especially paige and the kids um
the kids are straight into full french
school which has been very interesting
um
yeah so it's been the first the first
four months has been yeah pretty tough
yeah how old are your kids
um so huxley my eldest boy is uh six
toby is five so he is pretty quickly
thereafter and two she was um
she's tuned out and have you found the
whole lifestyle in france are you
enjoying it you're starting to now yeah
the first the first part is obviously
just a bit of a shock
with anywhere if you're moving your
whole family and different culture
different language and
and all that sort of stuff but um we're
in probably one of the nicest parts of
the world
and south of france and
stone's throw from
spain and
and you can pretty much fly anywhere in
europe and
for an hour and you're in a different
country so your sudden cereal and the
kids are better at drop-offs at school
they're not they're not crying as much
so that's always a good song
but um
yeah bro it's it's it's starting to get
better and the footy how's the footy
side being
yeah buddy's been um
hard man yeah um
top 14 is is tough it's it's a lot it's
a lot more forward orientated game
especially set piece
focused
big boys
big skillful boys that can
they can step if they want to but they
look to run over you first
or maul or scrum
and then they've got some class backs
but the the rugby yeah it's been it's
been a step up i think from top league
but it's just different it's just a
different thing it's not as fast
probably as top lead but it's a step up
physically in in in different areas and
however it's going
yeah we're at the bottom at the moment
but um
we've had a couple of couple of close
games that if if they've gone our way
then would be maybe 11th instead of 14
so there's only about four points which
is one win from 10th place to 14th place
so
we just need to we just need to string
some confidence together with the boys
and and get a result and
they'll change it i think um the boys
have
lost five on the trot i've been injured
unfortunately but um
so the confidence is down and it's
pretty hard to stop that kind of
momentum
when it starts to snowball
is there a promotion relegation how does
that work is it automatic
so the 14th place if you come 14th you
automatically go down to project 2
that's not where you want to be um so
13th place
gets to play the second
so so if you win probably two you go
straight up
and if you come second you get to play
the 13th
and and top 14 so it's kind of like a
promotional relegation
and that's um how barrett's got in last
year they bit um bail and and a kickoff
like a 22.
yeah it was a 22 kickoff and um our
number eight um stefan armitage got it
got one of the kicks over and and that's
how we how we got up and and top 14 so
what was the kickoff score was it what
four i know i'm not too sure i think um
so
i think the the first two or three had
all got it from both sides and then they
missed one and then steph
the number eight
went up and got
yeah
oh so much from each club relies on this
one kick from a number eight who's
probably never kicked the goal before i
know
yeah he he doesn't want to be the he
doesn't want to be a third choice he
wants to be doing every single catch
going from from now on
which i probably will let him
yeah well fair enough
and how how long are you at the club are
you signed on post this year
yeah so um
i was signed for a two-year deal so
this season and next season um
so yeah it was it was more i didn't
really want to move the family over for
just one year and
i think the kids being five and six the
boys being five from six sorry um it's a
great age to learn new language and
two years
in full french school i think they'll
they'll have a good grasp by then and if
we really love it then
you know we we might stay or and if not
we'll
head back home and and see what happens
and opens up after that how is your
family's french are your kids are as
intelligent as you ah
[Music]
oh man yeah that's not as intelligent as
me they'll take at least 10 years to get
the french down pat to be fair um
now they know a lot more than they lit
on i think so like
i'll be in the shop or something or
someone will be saying something and
then my son
huxley or toby will come up and just be
like oh he's telling us to go there no
black hey why don't you why don't you
just tell me or like could you speak to
him or could you at least help me out
i think it's easier for me
personally just because i've i've
learned a couple of different languages
um
i speak maori um
i learnt quite a bit of japanese and
then french i'm in the environment every
day
with with uh rugby so it's a lot easier
for me
four languages it's just um
very badly i can't i can't even do um
english that well i don't even pass
he was throwing big words around i'll be
destroying the little two syllables
four languages so that's pretty
impressive yeah i didn't say that i was
very proficient in either them but yeah
can
yeah i think it's just um
it's a good opportunity
yeah exactly i can say hello i can ask
for a beer i can
ask for something else so it's
anyway got plenty to get through in your
journey one of the great careers
um but as always we need to start at the
start so um what was it like for the
young elliot dixon yeah elliot dixon um
well mate i had my first game of rugby
when i was three years old
i um started with my brother who's a
couple years older than me yeah
and we played for a week club
and christchurch called suburbs which
was like um which my dad used to play
for and they um they used to be quite a
good club back in the day
and yeah it was just growing up and
loving it and it was full on tackle back
in those days which wasn't much of
tackles really to be honest it was
tripping up over each other and
i didn't know what i was doing half the
time just there take the oranges at half
time and and run around and have fun and
yes i was christchurch that's where i
was born and
raised and brought up to
live and breathe rugby and then we went
to sydney at a young age and
after
playing for cinema for a while i went to
saint pete's so yeah it changed from
club rugby to um first 15 rugby and
school boy rugby and what were you like
as a teenager i could imagine you being
at the skate park or doing all sorts of
teenage stuff
hey
yeah i was probably a naughty kid i was
a naughty kid to be honest i was um
yeah i wasn't i'd never skated can't
skate i still can't skate um
near i can't surf can't do anything like
that but i was just yeah i just was um
i was there for a while to eat my lunch
and and to train and to play rugby and
um just to hang out with my mates really
probably got around the bad bad crowd
for a little bit but um
my parents
thankfully sent me boarding in my last
year of um of school which was a god
scene because um i got to
be at school the whole time and i
probably played my best rugby
for the first thing that year as well
and then it kind of just launched from
there and
yeah
they got me through that which was good
and i thank them very much for putting
me through boarding school on that time
when did you know you were good at rugby
was it earlier on than that or was it
sort of that period of time um i was
good at rugby
when i was younger
because i was quite fast but then when i
think a lot of the boys got bigger and
stronger
at that like 13 14 15 i i kind of didn't
i didn't i wasn't big i was quite small
and then so i was making all the rep
teams up until probably 11 12 and then i
didn't make a rep team until under 16s
when my dad actually took me to the he's
a police officer to the police gym in
the off-season
and in christchurch in central and i
started to go to the gym
three four times a week and i came back
from fourth form to fifth form and i'd
grown from maybe five nine five ten to
six two six yeah so i went from short to
scrawny until and then um changed from
being a fullback
to being a looks forward just because i
i've always wanted to be a loose forward
just because it looked like they had the
most fun
what was your gym program like at 16.
geez sounds like a beast
mate i wouldn't have wouldn't have a
clue i was um i was just following dad
and i don't think dad knew what he was
going to do to be fair she was off the
cuff
it was um it was quite funny
there was before i think now with school
boys rugby is quite like a high
performance and
gym programs but it was unheard of in
2000 and well i think it was 2005 of
kids going to the gym at 16 or 15 and
and getting ready for a rugby season
you just didn't really do it you
went to territory beach
um for the new years
you're hanging out and that was it you
didn't go to the gym and the police
in christchurch and try and get
swallowed
david it obviously paid dividends for
you ants and beads because you carried
that college side for a couple of years
there um i think the only team you
couldn't quite get past was the mighty
nelson college from memory
yes i know i was um nelson college he
had bitter better about that to be fair
but
um yeah we we had a good bunch of guys
from two years they just came up
together and
we had some really good players
and i think from that saint pete's squad
in 2007 i think we had three or four new
zealand schools reps
which was
unheard of from st beads at that time
kind of been up and down quite a bit and
a bit of a lull and we won them we asked
a cup of
crushes boys high so
um yeah nelson college played up there
versus them in the final and we lost
that we weren't talking
did you make new zealand schools yeah
you did yeah i was um i was actually i
was actually yeah co-captain
robbie robbie robinson was captain i was
a co-captain i think we were the first
team in like seven years to lose versus
australian schools
so it was
it wasn't it wasn't a good thing yeah we
we
we played over i think we played over in
brizzy
i thought you're going to give me an
awesome stat there like
a real success
[Laughter]
not just a real humble real humble um
co-captain first ever to lose in seven
years so yeah i think it was something
like that
and then you ended up making the new
zealand twenties as well mm-hmm yeah so
the year above me was like you
they had new zealand schools then they
had new zealand nineteens and they had
new zealand twenties
so they cut the new zealand nineteen's
the year that i could have been eligible
so i was a bit gutted about that so he
had like a whole year of
um i got signed in the middle of my um
form
and
like the crusaders academy thing
and um just trained with them and five
in the morning ridiculous hours and
six at night and um trained to pretty
much to try and make the 20s which was
um the big goal yeah
to get the 20s because if you got to 20s
and new zealand 20s and you'd get a
contract that's pretty much was the go
ahead that time yeah were you training
with the actual crusaders or was it just
the academy group no pretty much the
academy boys but it was pretty much all
the crusaders now or boys that have been
the crusaders almost all blacks that
were the academies so we'd come in at
different times so it would be the first
in the gym at like 6 a.m or 5 a.m and
then we'd get out before the crusaders
ors or the nbc team uh came in um and
then would be the last
at night to train either on the field or
at the back of rugby park so
um
yeah we're we're short end of the stick
but that's what happens when you're 19
and you i think i got signed for a
dollar
um i think it was a dollar contract
literal dollar contracts it was one of
the biggest contracts i've ever signed
for
paid in one payment or spread out over
12 months
i think they spread it out over 12
months so i think okay
yeah i got like 12 and a half cents and
then i got taxed off that as well so
cheers for that labor
oh good times yeah new zealand 20's
campaign bit more successful than your
new zealand schools yeah um so we were
the new zealand 20s that went to japan
it was the world that was the world
championship in japan
so it was it was an awesome experience
my family went over with her with us and
and followed us around and then it was
also a bit of a bitter experience as
well for um obviously different reasons
um with zach's dad
zack gilford's dead uh dying on the
final whistle pretty much at the funnel
was sort of the final so
um a lot lot
huge highs and then um huge lows as well
so um
yes a successful campaign but then also
yeah it's just a
bit of a turning point for
for a good mate yeah so what was that
like well did everyone get told that
news and the changing sheds after the
game was there
well no so we were pretty much um
we're in the middle of a to accept the
trophy and then we kind of just saw a
bit of commotion
in the senate stands where you could see
like your parents and stuff like that
saw a bit of commotion and
we're all looking up and wondering what
was happening
and then
i think zach got ushered over
and
then we didn't really find out much
until
later on that night
until zach came back
and told us
about what what happened and
as dad passed and and
yeah it was
really
a bit of a
somber affair it's pretty um tough tough
news to swallow yeah that's brutal and
zach obviously would have been
struggling over those next few weeks or
years
well yes and and then he was pretty much
straight into law blacks i think
straight off that um
straight after that because it was 2009
and i think he made the all black sides
of that year or the next year so as yeah
we we had a pretty stacked team
and cruden and
salvia drilling severe and all those
boys so we um
yeah had a really good team and we
played um england in the final and and
dave rennie was our coach and um it was
just when dave was just coming up i
think looking to obviously get into
rugby and
coaching and and
had
he's probably one of
one of one of my favorite coaches that i
had i've been
lucky just a great game plan like a
great fellow and knew how to build a
culture
um
so that everyone would buy in
yeah it was just it was just a good good
bunch of guys and we're obviously versus
england and we weren't expected to win
they had courtney laws and all those
boys and um we i think we put 40 on them
in the end so
yeah it's just it was just a
well coached team and with
some
some really really good backs and us
forwards we're just battling away at the
front holding your eye
you know trying to
and then when you got back did you have
a decision to make uh to stay in
canterbury or head down to southland was
that an opportunity um that you just
couldn't turn down to head down to
southland yeah so i was kind of lifting
the lurch a little bit with um
canterbury they kind of said yes we're
looking to
to sign you but we we're gonna wait to
see if um so-and-so signs and if they do
then we won't have space but if they
don't then we'll sign you whereas um i'd
obviously been in the 20s team with um
robbie robinson and me and him good
mates and he said look
come down we've got a great um
atmosphere down here and they just won
the shield as well and then i got a
offer on the table
with more money than i had seen um
that's a lot more than a dollar anyway
so
i uh is quite a
easy decision for me to get an
opportunity to play
a good rugby because there's going to be
shield challenges to get
a chance to play in front of it was
going to be big crowds because southland
hadn't had the shield for 50 or
52 years or whatever it was so it was
pretty quickly signed and and
on the way down there
and how did you find the culture down
there we've obviously had um jamie
mcintosh on and good john hardy on
couple of south and lads as well so um
they've told a few stories
uh how did you find it yes please
um
oh it was probably the best introduction
into a semi-professional rugby
environment i think you could have as a
19 20 year old um
like yeah like train hard play good
rugby but then afterwards enjoy yourself
like the the bar was packed after that
we'd always go back to the spates our
house and cargo because there's probably
one or two bars and
and um go back there and everything was
put on so it was literally you'd sit
down with
every single player in the team
management
coaches
physios
doctors and you'd you just have a good
night until
three or four and then you do that every
single week for a couple years but um
yeah it was it was a cool introduction
to rugby and what was your uh initiation
like i heard it was something to do with
milk sounded like a good one
oh
initiation
oh yeah i think we had to
if i'm not mistaken when you get your
first game for the stags you have to do
uh your skull a couple beers do stags
raw
and then
that's that's usually just the the
docile kind of bit and then at the end
of the year we had a trip to queenstown
which was usually always the the best
time of year so we'd rent out a bus
would stop off at every single pub on
the way to queenstown from invercargill
stayed the night at the backpackers
and then day two would go to arrowtown
and then come back the other way
and um
there'd be like a yellow jersey leader
and
all that sort of stuff but on um
on the first day
there's always an initiation where you
the first years have to do like um
it's pretty much like a down up with
bears but then milk in the middle as
well so you do it down up drink a beer
run keep running then down up drink a
milk
running down up drink a beer yes
sculling the bed you're not just
drinking it and then
obviously up at every beautiful step and
um
yeah
this was before this was before social
media and
and um
iphones or camera phones really took off
so it was probably for the best to be
fair it was
quite
it was quite a
quite a cool experience but then also
looking back um got away with murder
probably how many shadows did you have
today
i
felt like a lot but it was probably
walking pace by the time i was doing it
um i think we had to do it was
it was either two milks and four beers
or something like that no 10 meters
apart so it might have been six but it
took
different people different times and
yeah so it was it was just a it was just
a crack up everyone would just get in
behind everyone and
obviously
just yelling abuse and
this is when even like the physios and
stuff were coming and some of the snc
were on the on the on on board as well
and
the coaches came on the first day it's
like you'd never see that
and in a professional environment these
days but um
back in 2009-2010 that's what happened
with steve that's good stuff and what
was your favorite um shield game
it was probably otago
that was our first shield game so we'd
played obviously the lahore cup um
winners and meads cup winners
um so i think it was
i don't remember who we played i think
we played
either
north otago
and someone else um beforehand for those
but the first game
our first shield defense was versus
otago
and numbers at rugby park and it was
packed like
i reckon twenty thousand twenty thousand
people is it was
my favorite match just because it was an
introduction for me to
professional rugby and um
to shield rugby which i'd only ever
watched but never um they're really a
part of and and the rivalry between
otago and southland and
yeah just the the hate
that they we had for each other even
even even though as i was from
christchurch i still hated them
um
but i remember having a laugh with um i
think tommo and thompson at the bottom
of iraq and like during the game and
he's like like slapping me on the head
and i was like
this is random he's in all black and
we're playing and
in a field match and then picago was is
quite a surreal moment it was quite cool
you were what 19. was this your debut
game yeah um it was my debut npc yeah
yeah
i played the two previous
games
um so that was my first first class
debut was first
north otago i think but then yeah my npc
debuts versus otago and
shield match so it's pretty pretty
special to get a debut like that yeah
what were your nerves like leading up to
that game i could imagine you being you
look like a very calm customer but even
at that age what we like yeah i like i
still get nervous now like i'm
i think if it's online to my 13th 14th
year i still get nervous but i think
that's a good thing like if you don't
get nervous about a game or something
then you're not
an uncomfortable position and you want
to be uncomfortable to get growth in or
to play well or um to perform so
i i do remember throwing up for that
game that's the first time and only time
i've ever thrown up um
i'm blaming the doctor though
because he gave me some he gave me some
bad caffeine
pills i think it was so i blamed the
doctor
and um
yeah the nerves here i was wrecked until
the kickoff and then as soon as the
kickoff goes i'm sweet like
yeah it doesn't doesn't phase me after
that
when did the decision to go move to the
highlanders come about did you or was it
always the highlanders for you um no it
was open i was open
market for anything but they were the
first ones to come calling um so they
actually came calling after only seven
games of my first npc season so
just before just after my birthday they
offered this two-year contract
and yeah signed it straight away pretty
much just said yep
i want to give it a go they they were a
gritty team let's just say they weren't
the best teams
at the time but they were always in with
a chance of winning
um and then also exciting because they
had
new new coaches coming and wappa was the
captain at the time so he was he was in
my ear trying to get me to come and
there's quite a few of the southern boys
at that time we pretty much had a
starting 15 of super rugby players so
yeah it was a pretty quick decision to
to get get on board the islander train
quickly you said they weren't the best
when you arrived but
they you got them right to the very top
didn't yeah you got them all the way
there carrying them on your back
not me mate not me it was a lot of
a lot of jamie joe just down ups and
twelve rounds and
fights and
it was a the first couple years i think
was was an eye-opener for me as a
just as just a professional outfit
we were um a good enough team
from 1 to 15 but then um
in the injuries or after 10 games we we
fell off that's because usually
jamie joe didn't rotate or didn't allow
younger players to play in
or death so so there was yeah that's
pretty much
we bought the brunt of that when we
tried to buy a championship in 2013 it
was probably the best team on paper that
you could ever have
like
we had tony woodcock with andrew hall we
had jamie mcintosh we had brad thorne we
had
luchi we had jimmy cowan
with colin slade jose giatami alison
all those boys and um we went zero and
nine for the first
ten weeks of that competition crazy i
remember that yeah i went what was that
you're calling each other
yeah
yeah
hanging out
but we finally got um
i went away because we played the sharks
at home
and they didn't want to lose to us
so they didn't take the penalty to
to draw it
they went for the
the the try
and um i think they knocked it on over
the line or something like that and then
the next week we flew to africa and lost
to port elizabeth
the kings we lost to the kings and for
elizabeth how terrible the season went
and it just went
it was a dark time for honda's fan and
kind of display so how did that turn
around
um
yeah that's a good question it was i
think it was a change of
of mindset um instead of just being the
betler
we tried to we tried to take on more of
um
like a rebuilding phase or like a
championship mindset and um
it also helps when you get brownie and
the coaching staff and then you we got
quite a few guys
from different teams that didn't get
shots so we got mokai we got waisaki
we've got a few of those kind of guys
that were there they're about from
different teams and but then had to chip
on their shoulder um
i really wanted to prove people wrong so
like a mark reddish
and alex hanley and stuff like that like
just guys that are just solid ball
players good ball players that would go
all day for you
probably not the best like
flashiest guys but then you put
a good game plan good coaching and a
dynamic 9 10
wingers around them then
yeah i think that's that's where it
started to build up and build up in 2015
it it really built
and it got you all the way but one thing
obviously happened 90 of the questions
that came in for you obviously about the
one try everyone wants to know
honestly
did you score it which one uh was this
like
the first one during the season
have you scored more than one try in
your career
oh that was i think i've got three of
them oh that try in the final go on
honestly
okay honestly honestly should we slate
clean
i'll tell you right now
i think it was a try yeah i think it was
a try like the only reason why i got up
shaking my head well there was actually
two reasons
so i was
because i was carrying you um i think
near here i think i was carrying about
four other guys on my back so i was
actually quite sore so i was shaking
like just saw me oh man get off my back
no no no no
but um
when when i reached out to put the ball
down um i saw bodhi's leg
like kick out
and i felt my hand go down to his leg
and the grass dropped and then i felt
the ball get like kind of like kicked
out and dropped
dropped it no i didn't drop it no
um
so like i was i was 50 50 on what it
actually happened did he kick it before
i put it down or did he kick it after
and yeah once i saw the replay obviously
yeah easily that it was um after i put
it down yeah yeah you must get that
question so many times do you still get
it now like when you go out and stuff
everyone wants to know it yeah yeah and
and it's it's so much fun because of um
like andrew mulligan and um bryce casey
obviously the hurricanes fans and i just
rip into them it just comes up on like
super rugby um finals things like in
five years ago this happened and i'll
just be like
okay
and then it would just be blowing up
every single time and they'll just hate
it they'll get hundreds of likes they'll
get commented on and yeah i do it's um
is quite a surreal moment because that
was actually my 50th match as well so i
ran out
by myself
to a full tag team about 35 000 people
my son had just been born actually just
been born he's four year four weeks old
with me with my wife paige and
um all my family and stuff like that so
yeah it was ridiculous um it was a
pretty pretty cool experience and then a
very hazy week after
yeah what was that like did you have to
fly out for the uh maori tour
yes i did
i know that sounds like i'm disappointed
but yes i did yeah yeah i like well at
least you got on the plane i know um
shane christie didn't did he i know uh
yes
uh shane christie yeah i think he
nearly lost his job because of it um
yeah he was like the wolf of wall street
i ain't leaving i ain't leaving
but um
yeah i was
i was kind of
just about to do the same thing but then
um
i'm glad kind of that i did go and and
play because obviously i was i had i'd
been talked to by the ball blacks
coaches and that said that i was there
and they're about and
obviously i just turned around and said
no i'm not going to the maldi's
tour because of i want to get on the res
for a week and a half with the boys and
not get out of my kit and just um
go to a
as much as i'd love to go to a court
session with um
mark ellis running it and
yeah there's a different goal in mind
after that yeah and where was that
maori's tour it was to fiji and my
goodness they had some big boys playing
holy heads
oh and they had
they had nadolo
he was playing like
wing but then he was
just doing hit ups
and seemed to be coming down my channel
every single time like you i was like
come on cars go the other side please
just go like left go left or step onto
the other side or run at our tin instead
of running at me don't have to run at me
i always thought it was just me
i'm always trying to send them back in
well that's why i loved having muddy
banks outside me so i'd send them back
out to marty
they're not going to run into me they're
not going to try and run to me they're
going to just run and marty
any other stories on your maori tours
yes so my first ever maori's tour in
2012 wasn't absolutely this was before
it was like um you know how it was all
blacks and then they kind of made it
high performance yeah morty's uh
high this is before that it was pre that
was pre everything so this was jamie
joe's first year second year of being a
multi-head coach
and we were touring to england so we're
playing and some random places we played
in oxford we played in doncaster on
casper don't even know where that is
right north right up north
and then
we played um like canada and in this
random challenge cup team
so
we go out
um one night um
in doncaster
and we're drinking we have a few beers
and
what we're drinking is duff beer like
from the simpsons stuffed beer you know
that that's the thing over there we'd i
thought i was like what the hell is this
a natural beer
and
jared huara is biting people hika
elliott is trying to tell people how
good he is at sweeping them and throwing
them over and
how he's never lost a karate fight and
hundreds hundreds of karate fights
and then we literally i i
turn away from the bar
turn back
and i see
15 lebanese guys
absolutely smashing all the maori boys
there's a huge there's a huge fight like
15 or 15 lebanese versus maoris like
everyone's and i i was like jumped out
we're all pushing everyone away we're
just all running gapping it because
obviously we didn't know where we were
and it was in quite a bad neighborhood
we ran around the corner there's like
people getting laid out one of our
biggest locks gets laid out on the
ground we're dragging them away we get
into taxis and we're just like just get
us just get us to get us out of town and
this is all kicked off because
chad toyota goes and bites the wrong
person because he thinks that somebody
else
i think it was him i think it was him or
it might have been kurt baker kurt baker
was on that tour too and it was it was
just a menace we were like
oh
there was a reason why it became
professional after that year because
probably too many of those stories came
up
it was so good
it had to be it had to
be
oh it's good
mate and obviously your highlanders
career
yeah very successful you talked about
your 50th game also your 100th game you
got managed to get to 100 games what was
that one like
first two years i've played two games
got injured james haskell had come over
so i thought i had a chance and then
ripped my pick and
um
yeah if you told me in 2012 that i'd be
playing 100 games i would have told you
to probably [ __ ] off and what do you
what you've been doing um
but
so there was a
an amazing
experience to to get to play 100 games
and at forsyth bar as well and run out
with my kids but the funniest story well
looking back now it's funny at the time
was quite scary was um
a couple days beforehand we'd done this
drill that the field that we trained at
was pretty dirty sometimes like they
used to i don't know if they used to not
fertilize it or they used to
like
i don't know i'm not too sure if the
sewers just used to run off at all the
boys from castle street that used to be
here on the first years used to just get
drunk and pass all over it or something
we're doing this drill where you'd be on
your knees and you'd be tackling and um
i had a weak cut just a weak cut on it
and obviously did the drill
and i i've had cellulitis which is like
uh before two years before i had had
cellulitis which is like a blood
infection which can turn flipped it
and obviously can get pretty bad and
was in hospital for two weeks but
leading up to my hundredth game the
saturday morning of the game 3am wake up
and just got this burning sensation
in my leg and straight away like i know
boom i've got it like the early onset
off uh it's it's already big it's like
swollen up it's like this this red color
and it's agony like in pain so i ring up
the teen doctor i'm like mate i need to
come see you right now i've got an
infected knee and and he's like oh okay
yeah come down um
we'll give you some antibiotics and
you'll be sweet to play and he looks i
get there at about um i think it's about
five six am
he looks and he's like
he can't look at it it's like this big
and um
but no i'm not i'm not not gonna play
i've got um i have games kids excited to
run out and i'm not just gonna be like
no we're not doing it this i'm playing
so whatever you have to do
to get me on that field you have to do
it right now and we have to get it done
so
he chucks an iv in to my um
into my arm
and pumps me full of like
iv fluid antibiotics oral antibiotics
take those some pain medication and then
i go home for a couple hours and i'm
just wrecked like i'm not sure it must
be just a side effect you just tired as
and i'm just asleep and wake up
for my alarm at 11 to go back and do it
again
get another iv some more oral
antibiotics and then um so this carries
on i think three or four times before
that even the game starts and half an
hour before the game starts i'm still
have the iv
like before the warm-up the iv sticking
out of my arms and he's just pumped me
just just before the warm up just here
you go mate last one i'll get you
through and i was like oh sweetheart
medicinal help run through
finally get on
get onto the field first with the kids
like awesome occasion get my midi
presentation and patoo at the end of the
game and yeah like it was
obviously wasn't hurting by the end of
the game because i wasn't thinking about
it um
but just a crack up story and
and just a way like of course that's
going to happen to to me when it's going
to my 100th game looking forward to it
and um yeah it's just it's just
something that you just can't really
describe what happens like what the
heck's happening yet did you ever think
that you weren't going to play
yeah yeah i thought like
probably when i first woke up i was like
mate i spent two weeks in hospital last
time
on on like straight on morphing like so
i was i was wrecked like i couldn't walk
i lost like 10 kgs
and i was tracking up to my groin
so it was um it's quite quite a bad one
but but yeah i think it's because i've i
got the signs pretty quick that
i was able to get to the doctor
for random time
uh in the morning and get that um
the antibiotics in quickly because the
first time i got it i only had oral
antibiotics and that obviously weren't
strong enough
but the worst thing was i thought play
100 game happy ass
they'll give me a couple weeks off with
the kids and i get to watch the boys in
south africa and
i'll just have a couple weeks off the
heel probably have to go to the hospital
and maybe get my leg drained out and
just carry on like that and um
the
team manager moose at the time comes
over
hey elliott um dicko mate you're um your
traveler you're traveling um we really
want you to travel okay
do you see what's happening down here
like my knee is heavily strapped and
it's like still this big purple
red and just like hissing hot
he's like yeah but we've got a plank
we've got a plan that was like oh [ __ ]
here we go yeah tell me tell me the plan
so they said okay you're going to sit
next to the doctor for the whole flight
for every flight
so we're going to go from
obviously dunedin and go to joburg
landon joburg that's a 16-hour flight
from sydney to joburg
and he's going to
give you an iv
we're going to put the ibm before the
plane though just in case because you
know
35 000 feet in the air when blood and
probably pocket severe is probably not a
good thing and it could be dangerous so
i was ah yeah sure yeah why not
hey every three hours i'm waking up
sometimes i'm asleep i'm not waking up
and he's just like just putting stuff
into my arm and i'm like this could look
so bad like
like people could just be like in first
class walking past like going what are
these guys doing i'm in highlanders kit
and
my doctor is just like putting
antibiotics into me through an iv in my
arm which he makes me hide
like every
three hours we have to hide it just so
that a host test doesn't
get freaked out and be like what are you
doing what are you doing there so it was
just
i ended up playing the game too and um
yeah i'm glad that i did go get to go to
africa because south africa is probably
as you know some of some of the best
times of your life
go on keep going i want to hear some
more about your african times because i
know you've got plenty of stories one in
particular i've heard about heard rumors
about is your time at the bulls after
the bulls game 2015 go on i don't know
what you're talking about mate where did
you get the source from i just need to
know who's been telling lies or who's
been telling
nah uh
yes i do i do have um
a couple stories from that actually to
be fair um sorry
so we were
yeah i might as well tell the story
because
james haskell told the story about the
the other incident and made a book about
it so we'll make killing me a new way on
this one and
go from there
hopefully
hopefully we don't get through get to
haskell's bit later yeah exactly um
so
after the boys game i think we lost the
game i'm not too sure we never really
had a good um track record
versus the balls in pretoria
it's just a tough place to play and joe
berg you're at altitude and
the first week's always the hardest as
you know
just trying to
get used to it it's like
trying to breathe through a straw when
you're when you're running and stuff
and the boys were a bit down on morale
after the loss so we thought okay so
we'll go out
so the coaches
give us a curfew
of two o'clock so ben smith that's
time's the captain
and um i'm on the sheriff so like
so the sheriff is kind of like finds
master kind of tries to implement like
those that sort of stuff and like um
regulations and rules and like that
dress code and stuff like that so
i'm i'm trying to back up ben and back
up the coaches with with um
with the curfew so we go to a place
called tiger tiger
which is um
if if you're very familiar with
africa together probably
a lot of boys would know what tiger
tiger is it's just a
it's just like a
a dance club kind of but more like a
long bar kind of with the big square
dance club and a huge dj set and a lot
of um a lot of people usually go there
and it's usually in the safest or safer
areas of joburg so um
we're allowed to go there only allowed
to go there and
not allowed to linger outside or
anything like that
first rule of africa is always stay with
the guy with the gun
on the security detail so um
so yeah we we get there and it's good
it's good we get there i think um after
the game
because the south african games we
usually finish it about like five
o'clock five pm so
um we start drinking obviously at five
five p.m
uh we don't get to target together until
like 11.
i'm i've i've gone we have had a mini
kind of court session where you sit down
just have a few yarns and
everyone's feeling pretty good
and
no one's really wasted or anything it's
just a good vibe and
it's having fun and then
obviously the rand is a very weak
versus the new zealand dollar
so 50 rand can buy you
pretty much anything
and and about so
the funniest thing i've ever seen is
we walk into this bar into tiger tiger
and the boys just go crazy and
they bring out these
huge bottles of gray goose with
sparklers
and like coming out like that and i
think it was like 100 rand which is like
nothing well no no it's like
maybe 200 rams
for like five bottles of this grey goose
i go to the toilet
i come back
and the boys have already started
downing them and everyone's like just
completely lost it i go outside i go
talk to i'm the bad a couple of the
bouncers and
um cuban who's the security guy i'm like
it's it's going to kick off and hear
that
the boys have lost that like
we're about to
go south pretty quickly
and you know we're going to go south
pretty quickly when ben smith's like
not we're pushing it out we're pushing
out the curfew to three we'll go to
three o'clock we're not leaving until
three i think i was like
okay if
you're saying three o'clock
and if the um security guy's all good
with it we'll go through so it gets to
like 2 55 and people and bender's here
and like come on mate
let's go to four
let's go to four i'm lacking hey we've
got to get going
so we i slowly start with cuban and and
um stuff start slowly getting the boys
into the um the band
mind you i'm pretty pretty um
pissed at the same time so like i'm i'm
probably thinking about i'm helping but
i'm probably
like hey
you're right
i'm totally i'm probably walking off in
the wrong direction q bars for looking
at what are you doing matt come and help
me
so um we get down to like the last two
or three people just like scuttling away
trying to get away from everyone so that
they can have the last couple more
drinks and
um there's probably five people left
benders bender's beer trying to get a
few other boys so ben smith is trying to
get a few other boys out
and um ash dixon's at the bar
and i would go up to ash and i'm like
mate we've got to get going
and he's he i don't think he even
realizes it's me and he's like nah
kind of gives me a shovel so that's
right like don't don't shove me
you don't need to do that
and then um i was like mate we've got to
go i'm not like tap him on the shoulder
he's like he gets up and takes a swing
and i was like oh come on mate don't do
that
we've got to get going we're going we're
going to be left in tiger tiger and
joburg
at 4 in the morning or 3 30 in the
morning and i don't know about you but i
don't really know the way back
so
i go up to him again
and i i've i've i've gone and i've
grabbed him and i was like mate we've
got to go and i've tried to bring him
with me like like in a kind of like uh
not a bear hug but like just a grab
and he comes and he punches me he hits
me
he draws me just gets me a good one on
the jaw and then i've just
the switch is gone
and i've just pivoted beautifully
just a beautiful pivot off the foot
right hand and just uppercutted bang
and he's gone down
and he's down and um
the security guards are like you gotta
get out they've kicked us out
and but the worst thing is he's not
getting up so he's on the ground for a
while and we're like well what do we do
so we start dragging him out
and this is like
we're dragging
a few of the boys are trying to help me
and then because he's a um pork's baby
boy a couple of the hawks baby boys like
um richard buckman and brendan edmunds
come over to me just about to punch me
and i'm like mate mate i was
i was literally trying to get him out
bender backs me up and he's like yeah he
was trying to get him out he hit him
first blah blah blah they called down
and we
were trying to carry him to the
to the van
three in the morning cuban
security officers like what's happened i
left you two minutes ago to get the last
three guys and now there's somebody
knocked out
knocked out
in the van
not waking up and i was like oh my
goodness what's going to happen i've
takes my i'll text my life and and it's
just
like i think i was incoherent as well i
was inebriated i think a stiff a stiff
um breeze would have probably knocked
anyone out at that time so it's probably
a lucky lucky blow as well but um the
next morning
we wake up and i i remember everything
that happened but um ash doesn't so
we called in to see jamie joe and he's
like
hey bro he going man and i was just like
i can't remember can you he's like what
you can't remember what happened last
night do you he's like
oh what what do we do what are we doing
with that no mate we got into a fight
and we're like oh no
no
so we get stood down pretty much because
we're meant to start the next game men
and both so we get stood down and we can
only play off the bench
and
and it's an absolute debacle like
bender's like
like oh
what have you guys done although
it's
tiger tiger it's south africa t.i.a as
they say this is africa just something
something's in those black label drinks
and those big bottles of grey goose and
it just um it all kicked off and
luckily nothing nothing worse happened
to be fair
it was just
oh and that is
such a loose yeah
and this was the year that you won it
yeah
exactly yeah
maybe that's the reason well no the
funniest thing was well not funny thing
is actually like me and me and ash like
we had played against each other um
quite a bit because he was the boy's
high and i was saying beats so we're
quite competitive he had just come that
year
from the hurricanes actually
and
we like he was really good friends with
nasi and nasi was the captain with
bender benson so
um obviously i'd heard great things
about him and good team man stuff like
that but we didn't really talk much to
be fair like we we played and we we got
on
but not
not really talk that much but up until
after the incident and then we actually
became a lot
better friends after just because we had
a story that was so crazy and so silly
that we and and he was like i'm so
gutted i'm so gutted because i wish i
wasn't so drunk then i would have tried
to hit you better and i was like i know
i think i've got a really lucky client
so like um it's actually
yeah i think that probably brought us a
bit closer because we just had a little
bit of a
a point of difference where we could
just refer back to an absolute crazy
night and tiger tiger after the ball
again right
one of the great yeah
and you you already sort of spoke about
it before but um the james haskell yarn
i know he has published the yarn from
his side of things yeah
i'll try and clear as much as i can
so
first things first we have a party
so this is 2012. so i've just had pec
surgery so i've got my uh left arm and a
fling
so we go over to um james haskell's
house because he's invited everyone over
just to have a few bears and drinks and
obviously that's probably not the best
idea to do anyway at the end of season
usually have a third party event place
or like a club rose or just out of the
bush somewhere so you can just
don't worry about anyone's house
so
the funniest thing is
he's he's at the time i don't know if it
was tommo or haskell they've got like dj
decks or sets or whatever and they're
like trying to do their own beats and it
was terrible this was before they were
actually
all right so the music was terrible the
vibe was all right but it was a it was a
bad season for us we ended
up i want to say 10
out of 14. there was probably just a bit
of a bad vibe in the area already and um
i'm in the kitchen
talking to jimmy cowan and um
talking to a few other boys
and it's it's all good we're sweet and
then um
i heard hear this commotion from outside
so go ahead look
and um adam thompson's dead
lima
lena
um to go throw an egg
and crack an egg over haskell's head
so i was like oh okay that's quite funny
that's that's quite
like obviously yes
you're just gonna wipe it off but he
goes into a rage like goes crazy and
like unleashes on
lima wasn't really expecting anything
and gets towed like it's
he's gone he's on the ground
he's out cold
and then kate pokey
if you know k poke you know k pokey
because you're from up up those waves he
is a powerhouse of a wee man he is
probably
the scariest man probably if you were in
a ring in a very small size that you
couldn't run away or use your reach
he's a very scary man like he could be
he'd be 92 kgs but 91.
91 of those kgs is just
muscle yeah all power
and he just comes up
and and haskells
and just absolutely just starts bam bam
bam
for days like just 10 punch combo 11
punch combo and then haskell throws a
couple more punches back and then
everyone tomo's in the background who
started it all laughing and then just
like obviously it's going a bit too far
and he's like oh [ __ ] he tries to hold
everyone back there's people everyone's
just like jumping on sides and we don't
know what to do
it settles down so we're all good and
then we go back into the kitchen jimmy
cowan's obviously got a little bit
heated and he's
he's thought he saw a fight and he's his
blood's boiling a little bit and he
doesn't think
he don't know exactly he then he
switched it and he switched
and he he's decided to pick on the lame
guy with the with the bad pick with one
arm obviously he's an easy target so
i he comes up to me
and he just says something real real out
of the blue like me and we've been
getting on really well
up until then like
we've been talking we're having a drink
together
i'm
at the time i had very long hair kind of
dreddish i'm in like a bomber jacket
leather
on my jacket looked like once were
warriors with the sling
black jeans black combat boots kind of
and
he comes at me smacks me in the face and
i'm like mate you can't be doing that
and then
so i just i just again i go and just
smack him like round us and and get him
good another clean shot which was
i don't know how i keep on picking them
i think it's when i'm when i get to a
certain point of drinking i get i there
must be a part of the chin i can get so
i got him a good one so he's out of the
he's out of fight quick it's it's not
messy it's real good
um
and the night goes on
the night goes on so much that we start
trying to burn down um
haskell's house well we don't but um
jamie mcintosh and um
jason rutledge are out the back by the
gas bottles lighting a fire by the gas
bottles throwing stuff onto this bonfire
and he has to call that he actually
calls the cops on us because he's lost
in a fight
he's got all his clothes being thrown
into a pit he's got his couch being
thrown outside he's got a couple of
people knocked out in the kitchen
he's got he's got two lunatics that are
out the back trying to start a fire
and then um
so we disperse we're out on the road and
um we i start walking to kate's house
which was just down the road a bit
further to carry on drinking which is
probably the worst idea and
out from nowhere pops in jimmy count
like the undertaker just pops up
like that i'm like what's the heck like
a king cobra snake just comes up
and he comes rushing at me he's like you
wanna go oh no jimmy come on mate we
don't need to do the summon sling with
my hair down
i've got to swap a crate bottom of my
hand and i'm like bugging this that's it
drop the swapper crate bottle and just
head back
head bottom and he's out cold and he's
straight
he's straight to the either a e or the
ambulance and
he's no good and the worst thing was it
was his last year right with behind us
he turns up to his photo
because it was the day before the photo
or two days before the photo and his
nose is no good he's got a black eye
he's got a busted lip and it's because
of me and he's like a hundred game
legend for southland and behind us and
i've just gone and done that and
i've walked home that morning at 7 00
a.m kids were going to school
and
my wife
paige is just like what are you doing
look at you you're an absolute manta
you've just gone and done this i was
like
oh my goodness what have i done what
have i done but it did get like yeah we
we're mates like jimmy
jimmy's an absolute gem of a man and
it's just like some things it's just
when you mix alcohol on into
any situation with guys that are pent up
a little bit
of psychopaths because we play rugby
anyway and um
usually spells with the danger for it
seems like other people at the moment so
two of the craziest yarns i've ever
heard
ever on the podcast is so good
how did the boys find haskell did they
get along well with him did he fit into
the environment
like i didn't mind him like it was
different like it's quite different i
think um if you took things to heart you
probably wouldn't you wouldn't enjoy his
company he's a lot of banter but i think
it's just
that
the english guys that's that's what they
brought up on especially whitty he's
very witty very quick he's obviously
made a name for himself um doing
podcasts and and all that sort of stuff
and writing books and he's smart and
he's quite quick but he he could never
get um
um retalic so callum retalla was was
part of our theme at the time
and
uh haskell had like a black bit of in
his teeth
and so calm retalic would just come at
him straight away in the morning sup
tattoos
there you go
and and haskell would just be trying to
quit back of them but they'd just ah
whatever get out and i think it broke
him like you really wanted to go
at callum republic but um callum was
just
just so funny
one of the funniest dudes to be around
and
yeah like i haskell was obviously um a
pretty cool to come and
experience super rugby it was quite cool
for him to do that um but i think
for us i think we as like a loose
forward we probably
weren't as
inviting i know that sounds bad but
because we wanted that spot we didn't
want
um to be given that spot up
um especially me i was really gutted
so i was pretty happy when cade went and
went went nuts on them um
[Laughter]
but now me and now we're we're actually
we caught up a couple of times um after
that i think i saw him um once on a
maori's tour and then um
yeah i think he
yeah he he's good at what he does he's
got some good banter and um
that's yeah can't really say much he
never did me any wrong
um
he was he was a genuine genuine just a
guy that liked to chat and have banter
yeah yeah
right what a what a islander's career
well we meet we do we do need to move on
to
obviously the pinnacle the all blacks
talk me through how you made the all
blacks i always love hearing the stories
about how guys were first picked and
their first sort of week in the
environment
yeah okay so um
we've played a game
versus the canes actually um this was
just before the team announcements and
stuff like that the june test series
versus wales in 2016. so we'd play the
canes at the cape town i think we'd just
lost
and um
the next day
we flew back and it was actually my
son's first birthday and um all the
family around and stuff like that and
then i get this random number pop up
and i wasn't even thinking about all
blacks like i'd heard my name kind of be
mentioned on the news and stuff like
that like potential bolters or
lists and stuff but i hadn't really had
much like um communication with the
coaches or any of the management or
anything like that so i wasn't really
expecting a phone call and i got a um
got a phone call from a random number
picked it up and i just took myself to
the bedroom
picked it up and then
yeah just got that yeah hey
um this is elliot dixon yep uh you've
made the uh june
all blacks test versus wales you've made
the squad the 36-man squad we need you
to be up in auckland
on um
tomorrow we'll fly you we'll get you all
your sort of stuff sorted so
um just pack a small bag we'll get
everything sorted for you and um see you
tomorrow and
get ready for the next uh month
with all blacks and i was just like
what
and i was i i'd kind of like went numb
and like i was like yep okay yes
sweeties like cool tried to be cool
count collected bang phone call and i
didn't tell anyone
for the whole party so i was like
because i didn't know i didn't i didn't
want it to be like
at the party or for a first birthday
like for my son and be like hey hey guys
i actually made door blacks but
um i told my wife i told paige first
quietly really quietly and then
i as my parents were leaving
i told them
as they're leaving me obviously
it was quite an emotional time
they cried and i cried and like
teared up and
yeah but i just didn't want to like
shout it from the rooftop and i just
wanted yeah it was such an exciting
thing just to keep to myself a little
secret like that wow huge secret like
that was
pretty cool
that is cool and then what was it like
going into the environment did you feel
comfortable
ah nah not really it was quite hard man
like it was the first year obviously
without richie
so
um he's left in 2015 and
i think everything was just like
under scrutiny or like everything's a
bit more an edge compared to what
apparently the boys said like earlier
years or years after were
because obviously i was only in there
for that year
um but my first week
it's just the introduction staff the
photos the
the christmas day where you go get your
kit bags and anything you pretty much
want out of there yes locker and um
your first day of training where you
wake up
four hours before the actual time of the
bus and you're sitting on this
um
sitting in front and um my roommate who
was my roommate i think of sam kane was
my first roommate i think and then i had
uh jerome kaino a lot which was was
quite awesome because just wanted to be
a sponge with
one of those guys
one of the best players in the world and
um
me and liam squire roomed quite a lot um
or me and romano romano as well so it
was
yeah it was it was
quite a it's just a different different
atmosphere compared to um
being with the landers where i'd been
for six or seven years and i was myself
and i was i'm quite a jokey kind of guy
at training
um pretty lacks
in meetings or crack a joke and stuff
like that but it's all black it was just
like this
and i didn't want to
really
i didn't feel like i could
be myself enough which
i did start to become
like
during later and later on
after i got picked for the um
the trinations and then i got picked
from the india tour i started to more of
my character um came out and and i got
more comfortable
but i never really got the chances to
play so
yeah it was quite it was quite a
a negative effect on me on my rugby
career it's just
that that like it was amazing experience
and loved it but for me personally i
don't think
that that it was going to be a fit in
that environment for me um
whether it's skillful skills or or
the type of player they're looking for
or
i'm not too sure but um
yeah
it was an amazing experience but
it wasn't
the be-all and end-all of my rugby
career you know like i wasn't
absolutely devastated
to not make all blacks or to never never
play another game for the release like i
would have loved to
play the lions tour but
it's it's one man or two men
opinion of
of a team that's what i used to get told
when i was little
and it's still to this day
you know like you can't really dwell on
things that you've got no control over
you play
a game get paid well to play a game
you can't really be
you can't really be complaining
about too much 100
yeah that's a cool cool mindset to have
because you because you did burst into
the all black scene the sort of
international scene and obviously i knew
how hard you were to tackle um in that
final
so i did expect you to have a long sort
of all black career looking back at it
is there anything you would have done
differently to potentially have stayed
in that environment for longer
um
i'm not too sure
um that's that's a real hard one that's
a good question
but it's a real hard one because it's
like
do i change personality wise myself
and to fit their mouths
or do i
keep true to myself and maybe not fit
their mold and go into a different
direction but just still enjoy my rugby
and still play
and maybe not play the test which i
didn't obviously so
i think
i don't regret anything that i did or
did not do
like i trained hard i
showed up i tried to play as hard as i
could when i got my chances
[Applause]
i never
yeah never badmouthed anyone or
dropped lip at training
if i was on the bags for nine weeks
straight which i wasn't during the rugby
championship i still always do it with a
smile and always be there and and
it's just because i love a team
environment like i don't play rugby just
to get paid it's because you've got 30
40 other guys
that are good people
and you get to hang out with those
people
as long as you're not on the pist all
the time trying to fight each other so
it's um
yeah
yeah i don't think yeah i don't think
it's a good question but i don't think
yeah
i would have
done anything different
what was the feedback they gave you did
they give you much feedback when they
didn't select you
um
it's quite an interesting one so i'm not
too sure if it was the
senior players
or something that they didn't like about
me
but um i got feedback
saying um
that they didn't think i took
either game day or training seriously
enough
so that
meaning like if it's game day they they
didn't like me smiling or or like having
a joke around or
or stuff like that but that's that's
just me i've always been like that like
especially under pressure i like to
smile like i've never been one to
on a rugby field to get into to really a
fight
i'll usually just laugh or just like
like i smile at somebody oh that's how i
deal with pressure like i don't
i don't get angry and have to act like
i'm um like focus focus i can switch it
on and off when i've been lucky to be
able to do that but
i got that feedback from them which was
quite
quite odd
for me
because
at the start of when i first got picked
they're like we want you to be who you
are
like that's what i got told so i
was being me and then i got told that
they want me to be
different
and then i
really thunk in when we went to um
like like that obviously talked to
brownie or um uh jamie joe and she told
them that
that he needs to calm down because they
said brownie for the first time ever he
didn't mind me having a laugh and a joke
and like he knew that i could switch it
on and off in the game and training and
he actually had a go at me
and hit me up in the airport at the
start of the preseason in 2017
and i was like hey
where's this coming from like left field
and then i later found out that has
obviously come from
the selectors yeah so it's
it is what it is amazing i think lima
sums it up pretty well when he messaged
me saying that
before the 2015 final when he was trying
to be serious um you let out a massive
fart just just to ease the tension it
pretty much sums up your personality
yeah like i was i was nervous as i was
so nervous to run out by myself
um
and then we're in the huddle so i've run
out by myself we're in the huddle just
before the game starts
and i absolutely rip one like bad and i
just start laughing i'm like boys we're
gonna have to move we're gonna have to
move and i think they're just like
everything just
everyone just went
like calm calm down like it's just like
one of those little icebreakers like if
you go on and someone tells a joke
and it just takes takes everything away
like it's we're playing rugby who cares
like just give it a shot give it a roll
um yeah
that was it was one of the funniest
moments
looking back at that they was me going
out there and i've nearly shipped my
pants pretty much running out onto the
field
at half
at the halfway line in the huddle just
before the final the biggest game in my
career
but you definitely didn't feel
comfortable enough to rip one out in the
all blacks
no i did that's probably why they didn't
i didn't get picked again
so is that what inspired your move to um
the black rams in japan
um
yes yeah like i'd always been interested
in playing in in japan
like i've always been um pretty
interested in in going to a different
culture
quite close to
new zealand one flight and stuff like
that so
um and i was
eligible to do that because i played
over i think it was 80 games for
super rugby caps you could go in between
so i did that for one year and then
i got my 100th game and i decided look
i've given what i can give my super
rugby it's time
to to go
and give it
do something different
and then it turned out that it was
coronavirus and everything just got
turned up upside down um i played maybe
four games in
two years
and yeah it was just uh
it was just a as my family couldn't come
to japan
and then yeah it was
just a time where
rugby wise wasn't going well
family-wise it was
we were distant
and long-term
like like trying to be apparent from
from japan when your kids are in
christchurch
yeah it was it was pretty hard that's
tough eh my daughter got born i went
just i saw her get born i was there for
a week and then i was gone i think for
10 months
but so i
mean i came back and she was nearly
walking so
yeah it was
madness
yeah and and is that why you moved to
barrett's in the end so that you could
all be as a family even if you were
overseas yeah like financially speaking
it's probably not
the smartest financial
move
like uh japan's great money and you get
a good in japan you get paid really well
and that's that's awesome but that just
wasn't for me
that wasn't something that i
really
i'd rather be with my family getting
paid a lot less
than getting paid heaps and
be without them so
we decided as a family to all go
try and make this experience like um pay
off and
and and see what happens from there but
yeah exactly it was just it was that's
exactly why we came to beretsor um to
france
to europe and so what what's the plans
going forward you've got another year in
barrett's and then just going to see
what happens
nate wouldn't have a clue i wouldn't
have a clue what's going to happen um
i'm going to try and learn some french
i'm trying to i'm trying to learn a
little bit more french um
but yeah just
coming back trying to get back in from
my injury i just um
got a blooming hematoma have you ever
had a real bad hematoma before i feel
like i got one most weeks
shocking my skinny little chicken legs
used to just cop them right i've i had
one and
i [ __ ] you not they got 250 ml of
dead blood out of that leg
i couldn't walk for four weeks
without a crutch black guys and i'm
slowly getting back and i'm
just like
and then
never ever breaking a finger and then i
come here and look at this finger the
first week of of france
thanks mate
can't even wave at anyone hey guys
dislocate my thumb
do that i'm sorry
what's happening
but yeah that was the body in the whole
scheme of things um
well yeah some days i feel great
some days i feel
like i'm 27
how i act i act like a 22 year old but
um my body at the moment well
when i had covert and the injury i felt
45 50 so
but no when i'm playing and training
like it's it's good like i'd play for
free it's just the training that that i
get paid for it's it's literally yeah
that's like
if i didn't have to train man i would
i'd be so happy but it's yeah
yeah i play for free definitely do you
think you'll keep playing for as long as
you can
i don't think so i'm not too sure um
well
i'm a big believer in um
calling time when when i want to call
time like i don't want to get to the
stage where i'm not getting picked
or get to the stage where i can't
i can't play
because i'm so sore or because my body
just won't let me i'd rather get to the
stage where i'm still playing good rugby
but i choose to walk
or i choose to go or i choose to do
something different
whereas it's because i feel like then
that's on my terms and i've
i've done my bit
when it comes down to it a small part of
your life really hopefully we we live
till we're 80 and i've played rugby for
what 14 years
or 13 years professionally so it's
a little miniature little
part and
is it really going to matter if you
played three more years in in france or
in japan
and and when yeah i don't think so so
yeah i'd like to
like i if i'm playing good rugby still
i'll keep playing rugby but if i feel
like i'm
either body wise mental wise or or
anything like that not into it or i
don't love the game anymore then
definitely i'll pull plug
because yeah that's always i like it
yeah i'm like i don't think
you can go out
and play rugby at a 50 percent mindset
or a 50 body
you know like yes you can with your body
you can stretch yourself up and stuff
but mentally if you don't love the game
still you don't want to get up and
train and
get up and smash people or
there's no point of being out there you
might as well just um
do something different try
try and do something different
what what i'm not too sure but we'll try
and do something different
[Applause]
yeah have you got any idea on what
you'll do next
i'm hoping that lotto comes in good like
um
lottery
big fan big fan lottery um
no i'm not too sure like i've got a
couple of options um
i've got a couple of investments and
stuff
i've
i've been called
very thrifty in my time with um
back in the day i used to save a lot and
i've managed to be able to put it into a
bit of
property and and and make some not too
bad financial decisions with other parts
of my money and
so now it's just
the goal is to desire well
no no no no no don't be silly it's to
have a job
that i enjoy
but like you don't have to worry about
paying the big mortgage you know you'd
like to let the pressure of the mortgage
like that that's taken care of or
yeah it's more just you you get to do
something even if it's not a well-paid
job but you enjoy it i'd rather do that
than try and financially just keep
getting ahead of head ahead i'd rather
just yeah
enjoy what i do and see what happens
from there to be fair
hundred percent mate you're right
you're killing life love it anyway we've
got about a thousand questions that came
back for the great elliot dixon so we
will crack on most of them are about to
try so we've we've covered that clear
not gone thanks for answering that one
yeah
i mean i didn't
first question from your great mate
aaron smith ask him about the bronco and
the mizuno boots oh
yes
this was my last year with the
highlanders
ran my fastest ever bronco
and mizuno boots because i was always
like i'd always be needed and then i was
like nah i'm
i'm not getting anything out of me
that's they've got parents they've
probably given them 150 grand you know
i'll give them drinks
drop some drabs you know
so i hit up mizuno
i get these
flash looking things and i do my bronco
fastest ever time my fastest ever bronco
time four four four
which at 110 kgs i was pretty happy with
and that was
2019 that was my last year with the
landers so thanks ezra for bringing that
up there was literally yeah it was one
of my best times and i i kept on going
up to people i was like what time did
you leave what time did
oh good stuff um next question other
stags the greatest team ever
lots of questions about the stags yeah
well for me personally in that era yes
in 2009 to 2013 it was the greatest team
to be part of yep
more so than being part of the
hollanders from 2000 2010 to 2013. like
i'd rather like i
i trained during the hollande season to
get ready for stag season you know like
it was
and i've always been wanting to get
about to go back to the stacks
but this this opportunity popped up in
brits and
so yeah the stack is definitely
hard there's another question that came
in a lot would he come back to the stags
and play how much
what's best 55 yeah no i think i would
if um
if i could come back and play
and and still play good rugby then yeah
i definitely would
i was about to do it like as i said i
was about to come back and sign for not
much money it was just more just
to get back to the union that
gave me a start
oh you're a lad love that okay next one
do you play the ball out of a bunker
oh
this is golfing no i never do
yeah
i never do i either foot widget
or
do the old um
swing throw it up with the with the sand
in the air no okay this what actually
happened was i ripped my pet during the
year in japan and all we would been
doing was playing golf because it was
the covert and the only thing we could
do was play golf so i ripped my pec a
little bit the same one as back in the
day
so i actually could physically couldn't
hit the ball out of a bunker for a long
time and then i played on that
for six months after it healed so
oh no i don't i don't hurt that a bunker
still to this day
okay
next one what is your favorite haircut
you've had and why and you've had yes
right here well i'll actually look at
this mate i've bought them back for you
i bought them back i've got the doozies
of the dreads back from the dead wow i
like it yeah so i had those back um
back in 2017 i think was
no i
had some absolutely terrible lids
i think if you go to
my
first 2011 highlanders photo i've got
like this little you remember those
little braids that you used to have at
the back of your hair and it was just oh
one of those yeah and i look like an
absolute clown
and
and i think i've just been trying to top
that ever since
just trying to get worse and worse
you've had some nice cornrows remember
the cornrows yep
cornrows um the pink hair in japan yes
pink here in japan
i just got really bored and
isolated from without family so
that's why i blame my mental breakdown
on that um
but yeah i think it's more just because
i love giving my brother [ __ ] because
he's losing his hair and i just love
doing random stuff with my hair because
i know that one day i'm going to
probably lose it and i give people so
much [ __ ] about losing here that like
i'd rather have heaps of different
randomized stuff going on that i can
look back and be like at least i tried
that at least i gave it a go
oh i like that theory okay next one what
was your uber eats bill a week while
living in japan
who's that from is that from berkey
keegan fury okay um
yes i did i
can count on one hand the amount of
times i cooked in 12 months in japan
yeah i think i spent
i would usually eat mcdonald's
at least five times a week
yeah like i'm blessed with a great
metabolism
very lucky but it's slowing down it is
slowing down but i've been blessed but
um
yeah it was it would have been in the
hundreds of dollars
per week
easy in japan and is that breakfast
lunch and dinner you're out you're only
eating five times into that yeah like i
didn't go to grocers i didn't do grocery
shopping
that's living it is isn't it
there's a point like a house it's
depressing cooking for one
and it ends up being about the same
price especially over there right yeah
like you go for a ramen
over there
and you pay like eight bucks new zealand
whereas you try and make it ramen at
home you have to buy yeah
you have to buy like 55 kgs of noodles
to get your money back after it you know
it's not that's not going to work
smart very smart
man
is it true you faked a dead leg just so
you could get a puff of the green
morphine whistle
[Laughter]
oh that's good stuff no that's actually
i actually did have a dead leg and
that's the one that i was talking about
recently
so no and i know exactly who that will
be they won't give them any credit no
like
i can i can handle pain pretty well like
the cellulitis and stuff like
i'm not
yeah no i didn't
promise
okay next one ask him about his drop
goal attempt at the new zealand 20s
yes i don't know i can't remember who
reversed but i did do it we had a
penalty advantage and i kicked it
just to
hopefully get the penalty and i think it
rolled along the ground i think it went
backwards i think i'm not too sure
okay you haven't done another one since
no
no i did not although i am 100 and super
rugby for kicking
was this one yeah
um
my hunt
no no not versus
the game before or after that versus the
chiefs i think i got a uh waratahs i
gotta
where was that from it was about 50 out
from the sideline
with the wind against me no it was it
was now is pretty much in front like if
i missed it or it would have been pretty
bad yeah
okay next one is it true you are so
humble that you changed your cod name to
maori wc after winning 20.
yes
yes that's exactly right yeah
um i did
that's how humble i am
no there there is a reason as well
because the other one that i usually
have malty gc was taken so i had to go
something else so i went dub c
world champion
as well
you've got some friends who follow
whatever that's for sure okay ask him
how he met his wife paige oh this is a
good one um so
i was
just back from under 20s
and was drinking a lot
and if you know christchurch there's a
place called bhushan which is right by
the uni and there's bush and subalika
and so we used to go there
because i lived at this place in
roundtree street
where my brother
stayed and he studied i didn't study but
i stayed in a uni flat
just just got
because it was by the uni parties
um
and me and my mate tahi and a couple
other boys
would go
to the super liquor down the road so one
night i went down to the super liquor
and there was this lovely looking lady
that was um
you know those drink stools that they
get you to taste test sometimes and she
was selling this drink called envy it
was in this green can can you remember
that it was this green yucky disgusting
drink i bought two cases of it in
in the end just because of
just trying to
just trying to flirt and um
ended up
her chasing me on facebook and that's
how it started yeah wow
it was just a random
random random ring thing it was quite
funny you must have flirted well at the
no no i was day three i think you know
it looked probably horrible i'm not too
sure what happened there she must have
had very low standards at that time
or her or her test is her eyesight has
never been tested
oh it's good stuff okay last question
elliot dixon's best advice best advice
yeah
so who too though
that's wrong
okay
the average water lead listener okay
this is the bus
quite a question bro um my best advice
is probably
mentally take care of yourself and enjoy
what you're doing even if it's like 20
minutes a day just
take
take time to take care of yourself like
that's
going for a walk that's going to the
beach it's
talking with your loved ones it's being
with your kids that's playing
playstation playing the xbox getting out
in the open air like mentally take care
of yourself and enjoy being
just being present and um
if you can do that
and have
some people around you that are good
friends and
spend time with them and
hopefully have a partner or someone that
you
can be with and have kids and something
like that and then
enjoy all that because it's that's an
amazing
amazing part of life and and you've got
to soak up because it goes pretty quick
because bloody quick i remember when i
was 21
playing for the stags and
now i'm 30 whatever playing football
hey that was powerful really powerful
stuff i feel like i didn't go deep
enough with you through this podcast
because geez when we got there
you brought out some absolute gems there
love that
yeah just you i'm like an onion bro you
just scratch away those surfaces and
you'll start crying too
mate obviously mate this has been one of
the best podcasts yeah this was some
yarn some of the best yarns we've had so
far and like we just talked about so
many layers like you've got all these
different sides too um
really enjoyed that yarn and really
appreciate you um coming on the podcast
was good brother man thanks very much
for the invite um
awesome it was just good to talk to you
obviously
it's pretty hard to to top this one so
you're gonna have to go big or go home
so
look forward to listening to it
yeah mate i feel for whoever's next
though for this one because this is one
of the greats
cheers appreciate it though man all good
bro keep safe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
you